hello everyone welcome to app101
breakout
today we'd like to introduce google
distributed cloud hosting mode
my name is andy quinn i'm a product
manager in google cloud i'm here with my
colleague ray
hi there i'm ray colleen and i'm a
software engineer who works on google
cloud and it's great to be here
in this session we'll first look at
market pinpoints and the limitation of
existing solutions
and then we'll introduce google solution
in terms of
how it's defined and what's the key
streams and characteristics
and we will then dive deep into the
product areas like platform services and
support
today the public clouds provide amazing
results and benefits so it seems
everything is moving to public cloud
but the reality is that not all
workloads can move to public cloud for
different reasons
regulatory ip protection solvency
concerns
those workloads that stayed private it's
very challenging for them to leverage
all the cool innovation from cloud
technologies to empower their business
and oftentimes there was a very special
and specific part of their business
as we know in public clouds
the infrastructure is quite transparent
users do not need to care about negori
details of things like hardware
operation
however that's not the case for private
cloud
the legacy private clouds customers
still have to spend a lot of time
managing their infrastructure
and most obvious pinpoint is that
customer will end up with a public cloud
and private cloud with different
development models and toolings the
resulted inconsistency impacts the
business agility
the market pinpoints are very clear
but if you look at the existing
solutions out in the marketplace
they don't address all those pinpoints
as we know
some products are built on proprietary
stack
there's no consistency between that and
the public cloud
application developed in private mode
can be cannot be easily ported to public
cloud very difficult to achieve write
once and run anywhere go
some private cloud products are very
infrastructure service oriented no
advanced cloud innovations like aiml
services and data analytics
and the management methodology is a very
legacy for example the modern
declarative policy paradigm is quite
common in public cloud
but most private cloud are still using
the legacy imperative tools to match
their systems
some private cloud products do meet most
requirements however they require
connections back to their cloud region
for the control plane to even function
this pose a huge challenge for sensitive
workloads especially in the specific
market segments like defense and
critical infrastructure
google cloud recognized those market
pinpoints and clear gaps in the
marketplace
we are going to offer a solution that
can directly solve those challenges
the solution is called google
distributed cloud hosting mode
there's three key things to highlight on
this solution
first
it doesn't require connections back to
public cloud all control plane data
plane magic plane can be local
it helps to meet the sovereignty and the
regulatory requirements
second it comes with highly
differentiated advanced services like
aiml and the data analytics
we believe those services are critical
to empower customers to stay competitive
in their own markets
and third
it leverages open source and open api
this provides an automated portability
and software survivability
which are super important to both
business agility and the submitting
needs
at this particular point in time the
google distributed cloud hosting mode is
still a pre-ga product we are working
hard to bring this to the market soon
besides the three key things i think
it's important to look at the
characteristics and the key strengths of
google distributed cloud hosting mode
the name hosting mode tells a lot
about the location and control
the solution can be deployed at the
customer desk unit data center even in
the totally air-gapped environment
this solution is not just the
infrastructure play it comes with google
advanced services like aml the power of
those technologies and google's years of
expertise are no longer limited to the
public cloud with google distributed
cloud pro hosted mode
customers can now enjoy those on their
own premise
another strength was highlighting is
that
the entire solution is flexible it comes
as pre-assembled and pre-configured
racks and delivered to your data center
as a service
it can scale from one rack
to couple racks and two hundred directs
it has local control plane built in so
it covers all solvented dimensions data
sovereignty operational sovereignty and
software solving
well it's built by google cloud so it
inherits the cloud dna
open and modern are the design
philosophies we follow when we build
this solution
we believe this solution will meet the
needs of many industries where they have
sensitive workloads and they cannot move
to the public cloud
but they still want to leverage the
modern innovation from cloud
public sector is a prime example of
those industries
with that let me invite my colleague ray
to talk about what exactly in this
solution and what are the key
capabilities
thank you andy
so we're going to get into a little bit
of
the technology that makes up
google distributed cloud hosted mode
and we'll start with you know the lowest
level the hardware
so google distributed cloud hosted mode
is full racks of hardware optimized to
deliver an air-gapped cloud experience
these racks include modern hardware from
top oem providers including hpe netapp
and cisco
all of the infrastructure management is
taken care of by google distributed
cloud these are things like operating
system upgrades firmware upgrades switch
os upgrades uh netapp upgrades etc all
are taken care of as part of google
distributed cloud
it also includes gpus
for aiml workloads
and it includes storage block
fi or sorry block file and object
storage right in a redundant manner
it also includes high performance
networking and in fact each node has
full bandwidth to all the other nodes
within
a gdc instance
and these instances can be up to 10 000
vcpus
in addition it's kubernetes all the way
down
so andy spoke earlier about it being
open
right
we've taken that and we've introduced
kubernetes apis all the way down into
the infrastructure management layer
so that
the
notion of an os upgrade is actually
controlled through the reliability of of
kubernetes
google
distributed cloud hosted bode
is a full air-gapped cloud solution
stand-alone from any other cloud
and so it comes with sophisticated
multi-tenancy
as we know in public clouds
things like gcp have the notion of
organizations and projects
and one creates a project before doing
anything on gpc creating a vm creating a
cluster creating a database within
amazon one creates an account to do the
same thing
well gdc introduces the notion of fleets
and fleet name spaces to provide that
level of resource management and tenancy
within a gpc instance
fleets are hardware separated from each
other allowing a single gpc instance to
serve multiple applications with good
security guarantees between them
and fleet namespaces like amazon
accounts and gcp projects provide
isolation between teams and components
of applications
policy control
is built in from the beginning as we
said earlier we're kubernetes all the
way down so all the apis benefit from
having antho's policy controller based
on opa gatekeeper and kubernetes
emission control such that one can
govern all aspects of the usage and also
audit
this means you could for example
take a vm and say no vms can ever have
the name ray in it and we can enforce
such a policy at that granularity
it's also extensive extensible and
customizable
so kubernetes apis allow for custom
controllers to do any sorts of things
we've had customers build
controllers that disallow launching of
new code unless there's an associated
launch process that's been approved
and
google distributed cloud hosted mode is
a rich and open ecosystem because it's
built on standard kubernetes one could
use the entire community of software
available to operate kubernetes within
gpc
gdc comes with much security and
confidentiality features built in
a local certificate authority
backed by an hsm is provided out of the
box
this allows gdc to meet fips 140
dash 2 level 3 compliance
in addition gdc can be configured to
work with an existing hsm provided by
the customer
secrets management
is provided using the common secrets api
but it's backed by the hsm to make it
secure
also
gdc benefits from google's investment in
making gke secure and all of the
enhancements put into gk so far plus
google's contributions into the
kubernetes community
identity and access management is
supported
using standard protocols like oadc and
saml 2.0 meaning it can be configured to
work with existing identity providers
that our customers have
and because it's kubernetes all the way
down every aspect of the system is
managed by kubernetes role-based access
control
if you know gcp you will understand that
i am is it's part of every control
surface within
google cloud platform
well within
google distributed cloud kubernetes rbac
performs and operates at that same level
providing fine gain control over all
resources
additionally supply chain security a top
concern
is something that we've been working
hard both on the hardware and software
side
we've been working with tier 1 providers
in each region and we require strong
hardware supply chain security as part
of the gdc oem process
additionally the gke and our google
security teams have been ensuring
software supply chain security in the
kubernetes oss stacks for years and
years and we've made many contributions
to making kubernetes a safe reliable
system to run workloads on
and lastly everything you do or perform
on google
distributed cloud host abode is audited
and these audit logs are compliant with
the nist 853 standards
google
distributed cloud
hosted mode comes with a variety of
services
and because it's built on kubernetes
anything out in the open source
community that runs on kubernetes will
also run on google pro distributed cloud
we are also working with
third third-party oem providers to
provide enterprise versions of popular
open source packages enabling first
class support and enterprise features
lastly i'm going to chat about
operations and support a key concern
when operating a cloud
google distributed cloud hosted mode has
a few different operational patterns to
support customer needs which andy will
cover later
but importantly the bring up and
deployment of gdc will be facilitated by
google every step of the way
as mentioned earlier
all the operational aspects are provided
and operated by google meaning that
customers you don't have to worry about
patching and os upgrades
bios firmware cve response etc etc right
instead google makes this
largely push button or could even
provide the support and operations to do
that
for you
additionally
the ability to support an aircraft
deployments google engineering is
ensuring that every area comes with full
detailed support and training resources
as an anecdote within the engineering
organization for gdc
any pull request that's submitted must
come with metadata for support and
operations which makes engineers think
about the full lifecycle up front
providing a higher reliability and
operable system
and you know regarding support google
gdc can be used in trusted and air
gapped environments google has developed
new support techniques and operational
techniques derived from google sre best
practices
allowing gdc to maintain a reliable slo
while also providing trusted user
support without requiring any data
to leave the gdc instance
importantly for all operations google is
the only vendor a customer has to call
and lastly localized management so in
addition to local ui local apis control
plane everything being on uh as part of
the gdc instance in air gap or other
environments
documentation and access to support is
also built in
meaning that users do not need any
outside access to operate and use gdc
now in rare cases if the customer
desires faster support we will offer a
way to send sanitized logs so they can
be shared with the core engineering
teams increasing support turnaround
with that i'm going to pass the baton
back to
andy
thank you very much
thank you ray
to sum it up google distributed cloud
hosting mode gives you the power of
cloud innovation with control
and it covers all aspects of solvent
data is on customer premise or any data
center designated by end customer
it can be operated by customer directly
or by an operating partner that has the
right credentials and the trust from the
end customer
google will train and work closely with
those chosen partners to insert service
availability
in certain scenarios google
can also operate in the deployment
directly with cleared and certified
operational teams
built with open api it means a lot when
customers want to ensure business
continuity in any potential black swan
events
and it definitely helps to meet local
government's regulatory requirements
google distributed cloud hosting mode
the benefits of cloud delivered locally
this concludes our session thank you for
listening thank you ray for being part
of this conversation
thank you for having me andy and i hope
all of you have a great rest of the time
at next
you